as the war in the Middle East enters its
third week AOC is already demanding that
America accept Palestinian refugees
should Arab countries be taking on The
Lion Share of the burden to absorb what
could be over a million if not more
refugees from Gaza I think there's
something to be said about the Region's
Partners being able to support and step
up Palestinians however that does not
abdicate the United States from our
historic role that we've played in the
world of accepting refugees and allowing
people to restart their lives
here no thanks that seems like a bad
idea maybe perhaps we could consider
taking in the relatively small number of
Christians living in the Palestinian
territories not because we hate Muslims
or anything like that but because there
are lots of Arab states around the holy
land that could take the Muslims in and
America is a Christian country and even
putting Christian solidarity aside that
means means there's a good chance that
Christian refugees will assimilate and
the ability to assimilate matters
because peoples and cultures are
different and there's one more concern
which might resonate more for
AOC why would liberals want to bring
these refugees to our awful oppressive
islamophobic country all we ever hear
from the left is how terrible and evil
and oppressive America is especially
toward persons of color and Arabs and
Muslims in particular does AOC just hate
these people want to make them even more
miserable or is that argument like so
many of the liberal arguments totally
disingenuous nothing more than a
fact-free rhetorical cudel for beating
Americans into submission to the left's
political interest right now Tex OLS to
9898 98 the G20 or group of 20 is an
international forum for governments and
Central Bank Governors who was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability last month the G20 announced a
plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their respective
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase you
make even if you don't follow
International economic policies all that
closely you should be concerned and you
should consider diversifying at least
some of your assets into physical gold
with the help of Birch gold group call
Birch gold today day to preserve your
savings in a tax sheltered retirement
account if you have an IRA or 401K from
a previous employer call Birch gold and
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you will not pay a penny out
of pocket they will simply convert that
401k that would otherwise be sitting in
a bank somewhere into physical gold that
can't be tampered with text nolles canes
to 98 9898 Birch gold will send you a
free info kit on gold if digital
currency becomes a reality you will be
glad to have something physical to fall
back on text Noles canw to 9898 98 claim
your free info kit on gold today right
now go to P talk.com P talk recently
announced that they would alleviate $10
million in veteran debt by Veterans Day
thanks to your support last week Pure
Talk is 53% to their goal with two weeks
to go now think about this we have a
100% volunteer military men and women
who raise their hands to sacrifice for
this country and when they're done
serving they come back to a tight job
market and an outrageous cost of living
expenses that is why I am so happy a
private like Pur talk has jumped into
help when you switch to P Talk's
Lightning Fast 5G Network they will
donate a portion of every new order to
this noble cause you can make a real
difference just by choosing Superior
cell phone service pure talks plans
start at just 20 bucks a month offering
unlimited talk text more data and mobile
hotspot just go to P talk.com canw to
make the switch let's rally together and
show our unwavering support for our
veterans that is Pur talk.com kwes
switch to palk today it is the right
move and it is the American way where's
the money where's the money proving that
Joe Biden is a crook and was pedaling
American influence overseas to enrich
himself and his family where's the money
Jack come on Corn Pop show me the check
well we got the check James comr who's
running the house committee on oversight
and accountability has revealed bank
records that that show a $200,000 direct
payment from James and Sarah Biden Joe's
brother and sister-in-law
to Joe Biden in
2018 James Biden got $600,000 in loans
from americore americor was a
financially distressed and failing rural
hospital operator so goes to Bankruptcy
Court bankrupt Bankruptcy Court says
that James Biden received these loans
quote based upon representations that
his last name Biden could quote open
doors and that he could obtain a large
investment from the Middle East based on
his political connections which was
probably true so James Biden gets the
$600,000 loan on March 1st 2018
americore wired a $200,000 loan into
James and Sarah Biden's personal bank
account not their business bank account
so you
got 600 is the big number 200 goes
directly to the personal bank account of
the brother of the now president of the
United States and on that same day
James Biden writes a $200,000 check from
that same personal bank account to Joe
Biden what more evidence could we
possibly have that Joe is taking
bribes there's there's no more you
couldn't have a more Smoking
Gun in a way I'm kind of surprised that
Joe was this sloppy I figured that as a
crook he would have at least hid the
money a little bit bit better one or two
more shell companies before it going
basically just straight into his
brother's personal bank account and
straight from that not even from a
different bank account from that bank
account to Joe that's all the evidence
you need I mean we had all the evidence
we needed when we got the hunter Biden
laptop where Hunter Biden is saying yeah
we're giving 10% to the big guy
sometimes I got to give half my salary
to my dad I'm not going to do that to
you though
kids yeah I'm I'm The Bag Man for the
Biden family is essentially what he was
saying we already knew all of that and
it doesn't really matter matter the
reason it doesn't really matter is
because of a crisis of regime that we're
facing we nominally live in a democracy
sometimes people draw a distinction
between a republic and a democracy but
broadly speaking we're talking about the
same thing government of the People by
the people for the people but there's a
dark side to democracy which is Mob
rule just as you can have a monarchy but
you can have a dark side to monarchy
which is tyranny just as you could have
an an aristocracy which is theoretic Al
good Aristo means good supposed to be
government by Good People small group of
good people but governing for the common
good the bad side of aristocracy is
oligarchy what distinguishes the good
from the bad version of all of these
regimes what distinguishes it is whether
you are governing for the common good or
for your
self-interest that that's the classical
distinction going all the way back to
the ancient Greeks going back to
pus in modern political philosophy
people make uh make less of this
distinction Thomas Hobbs famously said
that that distinction is basically bunk
and we just we just view our own regimes
as good and other people's regimes as
bad but I think the distinction is
pretty pretty real there have been good
monarchs throughout history and there
have been tyrants throughout history
there have been good democracies
throughout history and then there have
been States run by mob rule the problem
here is the American democracy such as
it is has already decayed so
significantly that people are ruling
openly for self-interest and so this
$200,000 check is not going to bother
the Democrats because the Democrats are
going to say well at least he's our guy
at least he's on our side yeah he's he's
enriching himself but who cares he's
going to enrich me too he's going to
give me handouts he's going to punish my
enemies is going to let me and my
friends off the hook for committing the
same or Worse crimes as the
conservatives and the Republicans so
yeah he's governing out of self-interest
but he's our guy and we're governing out
of self-interest too this is the the
line of I I think it was HL Menin who
said democracy is the theory that the
people know what they want and they
deserve to get it good and hard boy what
a great clip that was huh it was good
and what do you do now you got to ring
the bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel we'll see you next time